Android Wear devices are paired
up with a companion phone but
are not allowed to connect
to the Internet directly.
This is done for many reasons.
Including the following.
Saving battery power.
The phone is responsible for
dealing with internet and
sending only the important
information to the wearable.
Dealing with sporadic connections.
The wearable may not always
be in range of the phone.
And dealing with
different network types,
the wearable may connect with
many different ways to the phone.
So we definitely need
an abstraction layer here and
the Android Wear
framework provides this.
There are two main mechanisms used
to communicate between a phone and
an Android Wear device,
data items and messages.
Let's talk firstly about data items.
These provide storage
of key value pairs,
as well as automatic
synchronization of the data.
So you can create a data item on one
device, fill in the key value pairs, and
then give it to the data API.
Once you've done this, it synchronized
through whatever means possible to all
the other devices paired up.
The other devices can then register
a listener that'll have a method code
when a change arrives in the data item.